it's no nice to say that and Phil Jones
[Laughter]
sorry
[Music]
hi everyone its Paul Pogba and this is
Ray's my skills by spor Bible
alright so the pose okay Christian oh
that is beautiful
the preparation was very good kind of
Christian or gnarled oak tile top corner
beautiful the reaction of the other guy
is a nutmeg
I mean love it I love it his skills you
know sometimes he's even better than you
go think after the game is gonna get
McDonald Oh goal of the year call of the
year the person that is called the goal
he had the argument with the goalkeeper
before the game oh that was a great on
go know yet and I hope I want to say
that and Phil Jones sorry oh yeah
I was a pop boom ask God for you like
that but it wasn't top corner like that
to be honest how old are they six seven
students to be honest I couldn't that
was it nine okay six as a beautiful girl
okay I never see it again yeah exactly
what you hear who that was that was
class I love like dribbling and stuff
I'd love to see that we can make some
beauty of off the football you know
players like Ronaldinho to a bling and
stuff you know you know sometimes you
know when you see the goalkeeper sticks
you know the ball sticks under the
gloves and sometimes you happen you know
see that like that you say to the
manager take him out
[Laughter]
what did the person stop the video I
want to still hit the screen Wow
beautiful beautiful very very very
traumatic flattened disc that's some
Wayne Rooney goals you know and some
weather goes beautiful no I should try
that and let me come back I should try
that yes yeah we don't don't say to
money you know so the goalkeeper will be
ready that would become pose okay
David Beckham a beautiful girl you
should be protected
I think Janine Oh Janine you're the
master of free kicks so I'm gonna pick
my favorite and the number one get my
shirt Paul Pogba Mancha stain I ate sign
with a nice smile on it so the last one
the freaky does defer the salata mask
does the second okay see the reaction
and the first one is the kid because the
kid you know nice girl from outside will
be maybe more dream for him to have a
shirt so this child come here I got
something for you remember the the goal
you scored to forest road the one that
went over the Hail Mary
oh yeah so I sent it off to Sports Bible
they sent it off to someone and he loved
your video
awesome best midfielder on the planet
come on man you I'm pop over and that
was rates my skills this read rate rate
wait should I do the rap your accent
[Music]
you